All right people,
we are live on the youtube.
This is an impromptu live stream.
This came together yesterday because
there are so many forces in the world that
are moving so freaking fast right now.
And the man sitting across from me
has been tracking these things like a,
like a what? How are you tracking
these things? Like a mathematician,
like a mathematician, Eric Weinstein.
Everybody knows you already. All right,
we got a lot to do here real quick.
I'm going to go back to the camera
over there for just a second.
So I'm going to do about an
hour and a half with Eric.
We're going to chat about all
kinds of stuff and then, no,
I'm gonna keep talking to you.
Uh,
so we're gonna do about an hour and a
half together and then we're going to do
patrion only Q and a.
So only the Reuben select people are
going to get in on that patrion.com/uh,
Ruben report and a,
any people that joined at any level,
we'll be able to ask us
questions directly. No. Uh,
no censoring around here.
Great. Are you all right with that?
Okay, so the reason I wanted to do this,
and we've been,
we've been trading a lot of calls the
last couple of days and the reason I was
like,
we gotta just do this tomorrow is that
I feel like I'm living in kind of two
worlds at the moment that I've been on
this tour with Peterson for the last,
you know, four months or so.
We've done about 50 cities.
You've appeared at some of the shows
who where I've brought you on and you,
you play the harmonica and get the
crowd going and 3000 people cheering as
you're playing the harmonica, which
I assume is your, your biggest great,
your greatest professional joy so far,
but I'm meeting quite literally thousands
of people every night in different
cities all over this country and
soon to be all over the world.
We're about to do 18 stops in,
in Europe that are coming together
over ideas that are putting political
differences aside, getting rid of the
hate, trying to figure out some answers.
They dig what, what we're doing, what's
going on with the IDW, all of that.
Then you go on on Twitter
and everywhere else online.
And just the hate fest seems to have
been ramped up and it's not just Twitter,
I always talk about it in a Twitter
perspective, but just everything,
the articles of hating this one, hating
that one, all this stuff with cabin. Ah,
everyone,
these siloing of opinions has
just increased exponentially
and it all seems to
be getting worse. And that brings
me to why you're sitting here,
because you came on this show about
two years ago for the first time.
We had just met a little bit before that
and we started talking about fake news
just as it was bubbling up.
And I think some of your predictions
that you laid out or kind of right.
And I suspect that maybe you have a couple
answers to some of the theories that
you, that you dropped back then.
How was that for an intro? Well,
Einstein is, is, uh, a lot of
that matches my own experience.
And
I do think that these,
these parallel worlds, uh,
are very confusing. If you've never seen
what I've termed the vampire effect.
So a vampire is supposed to not reflect
in a looking glass when it passes by and
in, uh, in essence,
the shows that you're doing with Jordan
are a vampiric that at some level they
don't really exist.
He can produce people coming together
extraordinary impacts on people's lives.
He can talk about his disdain
for reactionary movements
and it doesn't change
the narrative at all. And so at some
level, there are two Jordan Peterson's,
there are two day Rubens.
There may even be too Eric Weinstein's,
but I'm a smaller fish in
this, in this pond. Um,
and one of them is a fictional character
that is drawn using details of your
actual life.
And the other is your actual life.
So one's just the media
caricature basically.
But it's a very interesting caricature.
In other words,
it's as if somebody has a
fixed strings to your hands,
into your feet. And so every time you
make a motion, your character has to move.
Um, so you have to start
doing these calculations.
If I say something a little bit nuanced,
I have to run the risk that it
will be taken out of context.
And my media character,
uh,
will end up saying something
that I find absolutely abhorrent.
And so the goal is to get you to consider
the consequences of your actions.
If I tell you that every action you
could take would be mapped to some
consequence that I will,
uh, right into a story,
then you start thinking, okay, it's
not a question of what I want to do.
It's a question of what do I want to
do given the fact that you're going to
caricature me.
So do you think that these,
even if they're self imposed constraints
have now been placed on many people
about how they speak and it really
had a think and how they act? Um,
you think it's significantly worse now
than it was even two years ago? Well,
because right before the election you had
all these people saying, oh, you know,
the polls were off because all the Trump
people that say they didn't want to say
what they really thought.
The teams like those screws have
been tightened even more. So I'm not,
I don't mean it just in its own
context and one lens through one Lens.
Things have gotten much worse,
but I'm actually in a kind of a different
mood about all of this, which is,
um,
I would say that when I first came on,
I was quite cautious and I
said that this fake news meme,
if you will,
felt very inauthentic.
Trump had just won the
election in November of 2016.
And my interpretation at the time,
uh, which hasn't changed much,
was that the people who had lost
control of the major narratives,
um,
realized that they needed to buy time
to figure out how they were going to
reestablish narrative control. And so
what they did was they created a shell,
in my opinion,
that they were going to have to fill as
they had meetings and figured out what
they wanted to do.
And that Shell was fake news.
So basically by pushing the idea of all
the Trump voters were paying attention
to fake news, that's what caused
them to vote for Trump. Right.
Well, so you have this
problem, which is that, uh,
when you have to call 50% of
your electorate deplorable, um,
because they're voting for someone
beyond the Pale. Now keep in mind,
uh, I think it's absolutely essential, uh,
that we unelect Trump as
soon as possible. So, uh,
I've called him an existential risk from
before the election and I continued to
do everything I can do
honorably in decently, uh,
to figure out how to unelect
him. You're a Bernie guy. Well,
I was a Bernie guy in the
sense that I voted for Bernie,
and I definitely saw him as the most
survivable survivable of the three major
options with Hillary, Bernie and, and, uh,
and Donald what I,
what I felt then at the time,
and I said so,
is that we should not have a
choice between three boomer, uh,
candidates, um, or older
candidates. We need fresh,
new ideas and none of these people's
experience speaks at all to me.
So it's not that I was wildly supportive
of Bernie and his economic policies,
which made very little sense to me.
It was that he was struggling
to be a decent human being,
and he was an absolute
maverick like Trump,
but he was a maverick who had
managed to survive within the system.
So there was a level of
trust that I had with him,
even though I thought he was
economically confused. What,
what I believe now is that we've,
we've been shown what got put in to
that container called fake news or media
manipulation and rather
than it being terrifying,
um, I, you know, I'm, I'm sort
of on the fence about this,
but I think I'm going to go
in the direction of funny,
like this report that just came
out from data and society. Yeah.
On the alternative influence network.
Had you ever heard of these people before
this report, by the way? I'd heard of,
uh, the woman who founded
it, Dana Boyd, and uh,
I've actually co-ran sessions with an
advisor of theirs named Hillary Mason who,
uh, you know, as a top
notch, a data scientist. Um,
so I didn't have the most negative
impression of the roster of people.
There's some people who I've used very
ideological, uh, over, over there,
but I didn't actually know about
data and society. It's sort of, um,
seemed to be an echo of things that
you see in the Tim O'reilly network.
Uh,
or
what is it?
The Berkman center at Harvard.
So it's connected up through
all of the major institutions.
If you look at the funders of data and
society, it's the Sloan Foundation.
Uh, it's The New York Times. It's,
I think it's open society. Yeah.
So bill and Melinda Gates. So what's
going on? Let's pause for a second.
People that don't know
what this thing is at our,
I think most people watching probably do,
but basically they issued this report,
the alternative influencer network,
and it was sort of how the reactionary
right is monetizing and extending their
influence throughout youtube.
And it was heavily based
on me as one of the people.
I think I was mentioned 77
times in this report. Uh,
Joe Rogan of course was included.
Jordan Peterson was included. Tim Pool,
who I've had on the show,
Dennis Prager.
Prager was interesting that he was
included because they included his name
Dennis Prager,
even though this was about youtubers,
but really they were going
after his channel. Prager U.
I think that's just an interesting
distinction that they went after the man,
not the channel.
Then there was a series of other people
on there that I have no idea who they
are. There were real white
nationalists, I suppose, on there,
from what I understand, one, uh, and,
but basically they issued this insane,
uh,
graph linking us all together
that looked like a cat,
six degrees of Kevin Bacon on steroids.
And there were, there were errors. I mean,
I know there's areas even related to me.
They didn't have me in Rogan connected.
I've been on the show three times. I mean,
you're going to ruin the whole thing.
Okay. Go ahead. Everything that's
wrong. Okay. Please. You know,
there's this fill out
to say that I know well,
but the thing is that at first
I thought it was like the 80s,
and I'd forgotten that we had
these channels. So, you know,
three's company was on there, he couldn't
believe it. The, uh, the funny thing is,
is that before there was no
way to fight these things.
Like if you couldn't jack into the
network of newspapers and radio stations,
there was no way to fight back.
So all of these things were terrifying.
But I noticed that I wasn't
a part of this graph.
And at first I had this like sense of
relief and then I thought I should just go
on Dave Ruben show and become part of
the alternative reactionary influence.
Now work as a Bernie voter
because, oh, this is gay poet,
pro choice pot smoking against the death
penalty on the air, right winger. Right.
You know what I mean?
As fellow, by the way,
just as a fellow Neo Nazi. Can I ask how
you spent Yom Kippor oh, it was lovely.
I broke it with bagels.
Yeah, exactly. I mean,
they've got Ben Shapiro on there
saying he's a white nationalist.
It's so completely insane. Yeah. And uh,
that it, it, it really
doesn't require reputation.
What it requires is a middle schooler
with an Iq of above 80 and a,
and an assignment to say what's wrong
with the methodology of this report?
Because so far as I could tell, there
is no methodology. The report, um, it's
not just that it's got errors and what's
what you explain what in a report like
this,
what a proper methodology would be.
Because from what I could understand
in the 61 pages of this thing,
they basically just tried to link us
together. This person talk to this person,
this person once interviewed this person,
this person appeared somewhere with this
person for getting the errors in those
connections. But that to me
doesn't strike me as a methodology.
It strikes me as just it.
Just human connections. People
Cross paths with people.
It doesn't mean you're promoting them.
It doesn't mean you're secretly
working with them or that you're in,
in a network. I mean, that's what
they were really going for here.
And I think there's a bigger reason for
that that we're going to get to in a
little bit. Well, okay, so, um, what,
what could they have done?
Yeah, if you were, if you
were doing it properly, right,
and you were trying to show,
here's a small group of people that have
created this network to extend these
horrible ideas or alternative,
we do have influence and there is a part
of us that is a network. So in fact,
that's not really where the problem,
right?
What you would do normally is you
would set out some list of qualities,
characteristics that didn't
pick names that you selectively,
uh, wanted to feature. And you
would say, okay, here's what we did.
We came up with the following rule.
Uh, somebody needs to appear, uh,
on at least three shows. We've done
this so that it's exhaustive. Uh,
and everybody who fits these criteria
is listed on this graph and look what
emerges. Or they at least
hold certain beliefs. Right?
Could you do it that way or is that
trying to say, you're asking me what,
just what I would think would
be a proper method. Okay.
So you'd stay at something
that was fairly neutral,
that didn't name anyone,
and then it would emerge that the
network was the solution to the carefully
stated problem.
And then you'd say,
isn't this interesting that when
I looked for at, at those, um,
criteria, it picks out Dave Ruben, uh,
and Richard Spencer,
and it doesn't pick out a
Ezra Klein and Sarah John.
Unfortunately, uh, you know, Ezra
Klein does a podcast with Sam Harris.
Sam Harris is named in the appendix, but
he's not on the graph, I think. Yeah, the,
you know, Noam Chomsky has
appeared on Stefan Molyneux.
So if you actually put all of the people
who would occur as part of a proper
methodology,
methodological discovery of a network,
there would be things
that didn't go your way.
And then there'd be a
section at the end that says,
we note that the following anomalies are
present people who are clearly opposed
to, you know, you might have Linda
Sarsour with a node on the network. Right.
And you'd say,
okay,
why is Linda Sarsour to two degrees
separated from Richard Spencer?
And then you'd have to say like, these are
maybe some deficiencies, may, you know,
here's some,
here's some ideas for further research.
But the point is that there
was nothing like a methodology.
And when you look at the
authors ideological commitments,
which she's very comfortable sharing,
they fly in the face of facts.
So there's no,
she's not trying to present herself so
far as I can tell as a dispassionate
researcher, she's trying to
present herself as an activist.
She has tweets from August since deleted
because she uses that tweets scrubber
thing or whatever it is.
Talking about how d Platt
performing people is the
answer to these problems that
she proposes. We have so, but it's
pretty clear what's going on there. Dave,
I could understand somebody saying,
look,
let's talk about what d platforming is
and let's talk about it in neutral terms
so that it,
it's not being used selectively to wipe
out reasonable ideas that I disagree
with [inaudible]
there's no pretense.
There's no semblance,
and that's why I think this is,
I have a different feeling about this
than I had expected, which is like,
bring this on.
Give me more.
Because if you show me who is
willing to salute this report,
you know,
is this going to be featured by
the Berkman Center at Harvard?
I went to Harvard. You couldn't
turn something like this in. Yeah,
into a statistics department or a math
department and be considered a researcher.
You'd be considered a lunatic.
And so if Harvard then salutes this thing,
that's going to tell us about
an ideological commitment.
Does the New York Times support this?
There's certainly funding this, um,
and they're funding the
center for data and society.
So we know that the Guardian liked it.
We know that vox liked it.
[inaudible] buzzfeed wired. I didn't see
buzzfeed actually. Yeah, buzzfeed did.
I saw New York,
I saw a New York Times reporters tweeting
at NBC news reporters tweeting it.
And it did it did it, did it occur in the
New York Times? Because I'm seeing no,
I haven't seen that.
I'm seeing that even the publications
who probably would like to find that this
report is reasonable.
No,
they gotta be very careful because
if you embrace this report,
you're telling,
it's so bad that you're telling people
what your standards are for intellectual
discourse. And that's what
makes it fascinating. So,
um,
so you want more of this
because you believe this will
hasten the destruction of
the monster we've been fighting.
Basically I want to know how I can help
them to produce more reports like this.
Um, you have to understand what the
purpose of a report like this is.
And I think somewhere,
this is my fifth appearance on your show.
So I'm probably getting close
to winning something. Um,
doesn't get more [inaudible] some
whiskey for the Q and a about that.
There you go. All right. The, uh,
I brought up this gated
institutional narrative,
and this is where this report
is supposed to slot in.
In other words,
it's not meant for individual consumption.
It's meant to be a sizable report.
And so it's got like high
production graphics and Hey,
it's a pdf PDFs or hard to make.
Like it's not a word document.
We go let you fix a pdf.
It's locked in.
So the idea is you're supposed
to be able to hold a conference,
let's say under the auspices
of the National Academy of
Sciences or Brookings or
Berkman Center, whatever it is.
And you're supposed to say, well,
earlier in the year we had
this fabulous report, uh,
by Rebecca Lewis at the center
for data and society and, and,
and they're doing some remarkable work
about how people are being radicalized.
And I think this is very
important and pressing.
And so you have a big serious conversation
in a closed conference and the
release proceedings, and then maybe
you'll allow the public in for the,
for the final day and you say, well, thank
you all for joining the conversation.
Of course,
none of those people in the audience
is allowed to join the conversation.
And that's what the gated
institutional narrative is all about.
That if you don't own a seat somewhere
on the institutional network,
you can't get into that conversation.
So you,
there's nobody who's going to be in a
position to say you realize that report,
uh, would not be acceptable at
any reasonable middle school,
uh, as a, as a data project.
So that's what there are some,
someone was hoping for this,
but I think even for these institutions,
they're going to be a little bit wary
because it's so nakedly ideological and so
piss poor on, on the analytics. Okay.
So when I saw this thing come out and
I called you and I was pissed and I was
like, Oh, here we go again. Just another
one of these things. And I was saying,
you know,
this is just their way of inching us
closer to d platforming and may be you
think, but you think that's
a secondary issue here? Well,
what I'm trying to say is, and by
the way, thank you for having, uh,
my friend, uh, Peter Teal on oh yeah,
no problem. That was great. Yeah,
we can talk about that too. Um, you know,
Peter has this brilliant way of analyzing
things is that you have something that
a powerful entity could
do. Uh, and then he says,
but the level of violence needed to
accomplish that goal is probably not
something that that entity could stomach.
Well,
I have no doubt that people
are fantasizing about doing
to all of these people
what was done to Alex Jones,
right? With Alex Jones,
there's so much over the top stuff that
a lot of people who breathe a sigh of
relief, thank God somebody rid
us of that terrible Alex Jones.
And I'm not going to get into whether
Alex Jones, good or bad. No. But putting,
putting lemme lemme can continuously with,
they could try to take the alternative
influence network that they have
identified off the air. Okay.
What would that look like?
You've got to somehow get rid of Joe
Rogan, Jordan Peterson, Ben Shapiro,
Dave Rubin, Sam Harris, etc. Etc.
And we've got new kids coming up all the
time who are said to be a major voices.
So are you going to get rid of all of
these people? Because if you do that,
the only way to do that is
in such a visible way. The,
the way they can do with this now is,
is harassment through algorithms where
suddenly you don't get the number of
views that fit the pattern. You're,
you're D monetize, you can't make money.
Um,
you know that maybe there's a glitch and
you're thrown off the platform and then
they say, sorry, sorry, sorry. Et
Cetera, et cetera. So this is just like,
they're harassing us.
It's digital harassment.
So do you think that we decided w crew,
whoever they say is at this point,
do you think we kind of dropped the ball
on not offering Jones a better defense?
Not having anything to do
with the content. I don't,
I've watched maybe 10 minutes of him ever.
So put the content aside,
but that there was this digital
assassination basically where it's like,
all right, well if this guy can't be on
Twitter and camping on paypal and Campy,
I knew to Megan can eat, can he have a
phone? Is He allowed to have a phone?
I have running water at
his house. I mean, what,
what is the publicans be allowed to
use streets? That's a good question.
That is a good question. Where are
we going with it? I don't know. Um,
so should we have offered, not because we
were defending him or any of his ideas,
but should we have offered man these
platforms doing this basically in
conjunction with each other
cause it all happened, you know,
within a 24 hour period. Yeah.
I thought about this. I mean I,
I tweeted about it and I said something
about this is ominous having nothing to
do with Jones, that all of these
platforms, Ddi platform to him d platform,
Tim sudden suddenly. Yeah. Um,
but my belief about this is that because
the platforms occupy a very strange
position, I don't think we have good
jurisprudence around these platforms. No,
we clearly don't.
It bothers me that we don't realize
that the shift has been so dramatic.
Or these companies,
are they utilities,
are they natural monopolies because of
the Cordy problem of path dependence? Um,
I'm not positive that we
have the economic theory,
the legal jurisprudence to just
refer to precedents and say, well,
this is a clear violation of the Sherman
and Clayton acts or, um, that, you know,
this is covered, uh, under New York
Times v Sullivan or who knows what.
I think we're going to
need a lot of new thinking.
And so the problem that I'm having is,
I don't know exactly where to fight
this and fighting it around Alex Jones
particularly.
But the sandy hook issue
strikes me as I want to
be maximally effective.
So I said I was very clear about taking
issue with the sudden d platforming.
But you know,
to the point where you're saying that
businesses should be allowed to do what
they want to do. Well is this,
is this simply a business?
And you know,
keep in mind that we have
very good information about
how our government used to
harass people who held dissident political
perspectives in the fifties sixties
and seventies.
But we've got no information about
whether or not this is being coordinated
through the intelligence communities.
We don't know.
I've talked to before about
Tim and sometimes people
call it time for technology,
intelligence, media. And
if you add education,
that is the universities and
the research infrastructure, um,
that conglomerate that,
that Association of major institutions,
we don't know what we're up against.
So how do we start
thinking about this issue?
I actually think that this issue
that you've just laid out here,
not just because it affects us in a
very obvious way. If I were doing this,
I actually believe this is probably a
far bigger issue than anything going on
with Cavanagh right now.
Or certainly the other ridiculous
political machinations are half this stuff
going on in terms this way that we conduct
and transfer information and who in a
sense of who you can get it and,
and yeah.
Well sensemaking comes on the back of our
ability to communicate with each other.
And I think this is probably the
biggest issue out there. And by the way,
I'm glad you just called me out on it,
but this is where I'm running my
classical liberal part that veers into
libertarianism is starting where the
rubber's meeting the road and I'm going,
maybe there isn't, I don't want the
government to come in, you know,
that's against everything I stand for.
It's not against every is everything
you stand for.
Look at one of my goals is to get you
off of the Canon hardcore libertarianism.
I think competition is still the answer,
but I do think we agreed that where
competition works is the answer.
But if you are truly free marketeer,
you should know about market failure.
Yeah.
And you should not pretend that markets
can solve all problems because you will
have a world that is absolutely
red of tooth and claw. Well,
I think we're sort of heading
there with this. I understand that.
I can't create a youtube, but
I'm trying to say that, you know,
all I'm asking is that you reconsider
your position because of the complexities
about, you know, path dependent monopoly,
which we refer to sometimes as Courtney,
um, after the typewriter, uh,
may have a funny structure and it's not
clear that we should break it up or not
break it up or regulated or not regulated.
These are open questions
and I'm absolutely,
I agree with you as somebody
who's much more in a,
in a classic progressive position.
Uh,
although that has nothing
to do with what people,
client claim is progressivism
now that where the market works,
you let the market work. Yeah. Right.
But it's not clear that the market is
meant to work here because there's too
many asymmetries of information. I
mean, Google so many of our secrets.
Yeah.
And so what happens when they've got a
problem and they can also read all your
email and then you're thinking like,
okay, well that's a level of power.
That's not like a company. You know,
maybe somebody can invent some,
some sort of email where the
company can't read your email,
but then the question is,
are they responsible for
regulating, right Zach? Well,
okay,
but that's exactly what the data and
society people are supposed to be doing.
Or the, uh, the Berkman
Center. The problem is,
is that we have a situation in
which it's as if the grownups,
whoever they are held a conference,
which we were not invited to and they
made a whole bunch of findings, you know,
that, that these people are extreme. These
people are good if you think about it.
And in terms of like the
hulk, the hulk, you know,
often talks in sentences that don't
have one part of speech, you know,
so the Harvard good, send it strong. Yeah.
Um,
well somehow they have an idea that
Harvard has our best interests in mind.
That,
uh,
more or less the Democratic Party is
that which has to defeat Trump and the
progressive agenda.
And I put huge scare quotes around
progressive here because it's anything but
yeah. Um, those forces,
the grownups as they see themselves
need to take this thing back.
And my point to them is,
are you aware of who you have in
this alternative influence network?
Because
I think you're sadly mistaken if you
don't imagine that the fire power outside
of the institutional network,
intellectual firepower is as great or
greater than the intellectual firepower
inside of the institutions,
which are constantly requiring
people to say absolutely outrageous,
ridiculous,
false things.
And so good people tend to eventually
get so fed up that they can't stay inside
of the institutions and the magic
of this alternative network.
Um, and I, and I mean that
in the good sense. Yeah. Uh,
is that it's based around individuals.
The main war is not left
versus right at the moment.
[inaudible] it's institutions versus
things that are much closer to being
individuals.
So the Ruben report isn't just you,
but it's a team that is relatively small,
and these relatively small teams don't
take on these terrible characteristics of
the large institutions. And so the reason
that we're able to be so effective,
in my opinion, is that all of
the institutions are fighting.
MMM.
[inaudible]
certain problems having to do with,
we don't have a,
a really dependable source of growth.
We don't have a great national story.
They're all sputtering.
They're all struggling.
And the individuals are where
the vitality and the energy is.
So if Jordan Peterson has given us a
biblical lecture on this right now,
I think he'd be talking
about David Verse Goliath.
And in this case it might be Dave
verse Google, but, but right. I mean,
that's the idea that the small operation,
the individual,
or it can be just a
small set of individuals.
We have a lot of leverage because
we don't have this cumbersome,
cumbersome machine around
us. And we don't, you know,
I have to answer to myself and a couple
of other people that I hold in close
confidence, but that's it. And that,
that's nimble and that's great.
Yeah. So that's powerful. That's powerful
even though it feels kind of scary.
But what are you writing on your right?
Great people.
I think you're riding on,
um,
internals pipes stories. Oh, you
meant you meant literally, right.
We are still using their stuff.
We're still using their stuff.
And if you take this idea, you see the
d platforming movement is quite clever.
MMM.
Because free speech is
enshrined in the constitution,
so they can't really go around,
uh,
you know, it's like somebody saying
you're entitled to play Your Guitar,
Your Electric Guitar,
but we have the right to cut off your
power while you can barely hear an
electric guitar, uh, without an amp.
Right. And so the platforming is, they,
it's a fail over into the next level
of where can we take this fight.
And I think it's very
important that people read a,
I think it's a transcript of a speech
by the founder of data and society
institute or Center, um, Dana Boyd,
where she talks about two important
concepts. One of, one of, in a speech,
one of which is data voids in a data
void is some place where people want to
search for something, but there's
not a lot of information around.
And
that's fascinating because
that's a lot of how the mainstream
institutions control us.
So I have a very clean example of this.
The idea that you can be a immigration
restrictionist and a clear xenophile like
everything throughout your life speaks
to your interest in foreign cultures,
your openness to other people.
But you happen to be a restrictions.
There is a complete void.
If you go search xenophile restrictionist
you'll probably find me at the top
because what may be a majority position
in the United States is acknowledged
nowhere. Meaning that you might
be into other cultures do,
you might even be married to an Indian
woman. You might love all sorts of things,
speak a kajillion languages.
Every time I get in a car with you,
you're speaking in another language,
you might care about all these other
cultures for a million other reasons,
but it doesn't mean you want open borders,
which is what most people think.
I think. Well, it's very confusing.
The Di, uh, an analogy would be, um,
do you wish to adopt, uh, every
person have over for dinner.
The idea of being open to dinner guests
and expecting that as much as you love
them,
they will probably leave,
if not after dinner that after a few
days or a few weeks you kicked me out.
But I was drunk. I did, I'd be
Runco. Alright. Focus. Sorry.
So we have a situation in
which these data voids, um,
are real and they're created
by the unwillingness to report.
Now this is what's radicalizing people.
So that's what,
that was one of the forest types of fake
news you originally discussed, right?
Avoidance about an important
topic is actually a title.
Let's see if I can remember the, yeah,
let's see if he can do it. All right.
So there was algorithmic, there
was institutional, I mean,
give me an example of each one as your
algorithmic fake news has to do with the,
there's something important, but you
can't find it via via search and it's,
it's down ranked. So that a, it's,
it's effectively suppressed and
something else is accentuated. Um,
there was institutional where
any institution that wants, um,
can, uh, broadcast information and
people treat it as if it's news. Um,
but individuals can not do this.
Then there was narrative fake news where
the New York Times is the principle
offender here,
which they figure out the narrative,
the narrative arc ahead of time.
And we don't know why they would do that
because the, the facts haven't come in,
but they have an idea of how the facts
should be organized as they come in.
And then there's just false news. Yeah.
So these, but wasn't one of them. Oh,
so the first one is what you're saying
[inaudible] is the closest Scott it,
but sometimes that occurs just naturally.
Like what if nobody thought, why aren't,
why don't we have articles on
xenophile file? Restrictionist oh,
we just forgot.
We forgot about what may be a majority
position in the United States. Um,
but it's like,
it's so large that it's pretending that
you can't find an aircraft carrier in a,
in a,
in a community harbor.
So that's what makes people
crazy. So the, the, the,
the big data voids if you will,
are people who believe that, um,
let's say that a trade is generally good,
but that it isn't a rising tide that
raises all ships and that you have to do
work around it to make sure you don't
decimate communities and states, you know,
uh, there was very little,
um, real work done on what,
what the effects of trade would be.
Uh, immigration we just mentioned.
And then there's the, the, I believe that
there is a linkage between terror, uh,
and Islam,
but I'm,
I would think is Llama fillic because
I'm fascinated by the culture,
religion and uh, find it
very easy to, to, you know,
socialize in that portion of the world
because it's very similar to many of the
values that I hold.
We just had a great night with your,
what best friend from college who
happens to be Muslim damn. Well,
it's like who even noticed it doesn't,
right.
So the,
by creating these voice saying,
don't mention the following obvious fact,
because if you do,
we have an interpretation.
If you disagree with us on policy,
we can infer that you're a bad person,
a moral failing,
we'll have to be fixed to
your name in perpetuity.
That thing is making people
absolutely hate these institutions.
And my goal and trying to
unelect Donald Trump is to say,
there is no reason that
Donald Trump should be running
the table by monopolizing
these data voids.
Yes,
you can believe that there is a link
between terror and Islam and not be
Islamophobic.
Yes,
you can believe that we have a problem
with the way in which we negotiate trade
agreements and you can still want to be
open to the world and not protectionists
that heart. Yes, you can be uh, uh,
a restrictionist and the xenophile
simultaneously though the,
those are my big three examples of what
makes people hate the institutions.
And in some sense I've been thinking
that Donald Trump is like a company
fragging it senior offers,
like we don't want to be led by people
who tell us that we're deplorable because
if you pee on our leg and tell
us it's raining, we say, no,
you're peeing on my
leg. Please stop. Right?
And those people who want to say,
look,
we are the natural guardians of America.
We know who needs to be the platform.
We know, um, who, who shouldn't
have access to paypal.
We should be able to write our terms of
service in such a way that pure virtue
is boosted and not niceness
is pushed down. By the way,
pure virtue is everybody. I
like nobody. [inaudible] right,
right, right. Okay. Well,
none of us want to be governed by this.
Nobody who loves liberty and loves
this particular country and loves the
enlightenment,
wants to be governed by this.
And so this is an unwanted institutional
class and we're trying to throw them
off. What happened was it was so uniform
throughout the institutions that they
couldn't field candidates
that spoke to this fed upness.
I mean we were just fed up who are,
who are these baby boomers who are
entitled to tell us how to think.
And I'm saying, this is somebody who
comes, you know, from, from the left.
It shouldn't be a left,
right. Distinction. Yeah.
More or less people who have interesting
perspectives as individuals are looking
at this and say, we know you're
trying to get us off the platforms.
We know your engineers hate us,
or are you reading our dms?
Are you going through our emails?
What are you doing over there?
And that's where this the Alex Jones
incident to changes in the terms of
service.
So now like you can be thrown off of a
platform even if you conduct yourself
properly on platform because of
you're off platform behavior. Yeah.
A lot of people probably don't know
about that. You are not making that out.
But this is, this is what happened when
I came on your show and I said, um,
I said the fake news story is inauthentic.
What I was doing was I was
putting a marker and I was saying,
watch this space because what they're
going to do is they're going to fill it
with some kind of machinery. And so
there's been a lot of changes. One,
they're all of these reporting mechanisms.
Uh,
you've got loud groups who objects
to things that you put them on a, a,
a truth in safety council.
And then the idea is that all of
the squeaky wheels, uh, who are,
who are upset with things,
if you give them free pizza and you
give them a place at the table, uh,
they may shut up,
but they're also doing this free work
with probably often doesn't need to be
done. I'm not saying that there
isn't abuse on these systems,
but you want the abuse to be even
handed. If you have a Hashtag, uh,
like as your client brought
up, uh, kill all men.
Why is kill all men? Did you
read this article? I'm not,
I'm not a huge fan of his, frankly. That's
actually in the last couple of days.
I find him quite personable. He's been
very nice. Uh, I'm putting him on a list.
He's had dinner at your house.
I've had dinner at your butt,
but he's also been set on a, but
he's also been savage, so I'm better,
I'm trying to understand the perspective.
Yeah.
So I'm trying to figure out is
the Nice intelligent guy, uh,
who came over for Shabbat dinner.
Uh,
the same guy as the guy who's
rationalizing kill all men.
I didn't actually mind his rationalization
of kill Altman. What he said is,
is that within a small
group of feminists Twitter,
which I don't think really exist,
people talk like that,
but since it's an open platform,
it doesn't have any walls around.
He said that inside that community,
that phrase meant it would be nice if
the world were slightly better for women.
So take that,
take him at his word.
You would imagine that that
same community, if it was
epistemically consistent,
would also believe,
hey,
we can't police microaggressions because
we have to figure out whether those
things are actually not
as toxic as they sound,
but that this is what's fascinating is
we think that the same community that
should object to anything like,
you know,
referring to mankind as bigotry.
Yeah.
That community should also be allowed
to use the Hashtag kill all men.
Now,
that doesn't make any sense.
I'm very focused on are you
granting yourself a privilege
that you will grant to
no one else, because if you recall,
but created the reformation, uh,
it was the selling of indulgences.
And I believe that what the left thinks
it has is an indulgence system that is
Sara Jong,
when promoted to the editorial board of
the New York Times should be granted an
indulgence because she's actually a
great person and she engaged in some bad
twittery and we should be, uh,
there should be compassion.
There should be forgiveness. There
should not be a black mark on the record.
So basically she believes
in all the right things,
according to the New York Times, you can
say whatever she about white journal,
but she believes in prove, you know,
she's a progressive and blah, blah, blah.
But this other guy who once said
something which was ambiguous,
should be be platform
for life. Yeah. And
I don't think without profanity,
uh, I don't think I have any way of,
of communicating how hateful
that is. How dare you. Literally,
how dare you suggest that some community
is entitled to own both of these
things.
Ultimate forgiveness for their members
and the right to police everyone else.
And that's what we have to fight.
So what do you make of what I would
argue is the lack of clear thinking on
behalf of these people. I don't want to
make it about as her, it doesn't matter,
but like look, a report like this comes
out. And if we were to Parse, I honestly,
I didn't know at least 10 of the people,
I'd never even heard of them.
A whole bunch of them I've had muted
on Twitter because they don't like me.
So it's like the idea that we were
all connected is, is just silly.
But if they had done a report just on
true white nationalists, right. You know,
they actually probably could
have got some of us on our side,
not maybe not to have them d
platform because that's not where,
where I would want to go with it,
but that there's this group of
people doing some really bad stuff.
Here's what it is. But they do a
sloppy version out in out racists.
There's an oppression they need.
They need a certain amount. Look,
there is still structural
oppression in the world.
I don't want to have to argue that I can,
I can make a convincing case.
So I do believe that there is
structural oppression in our society.
The problem is disrupted.
What do you mean by structural?
Cause this will be a big hangup point
for a lot of people. Well that you know,
you, you don't have anything that
is explicitly against one race,
but when you have a decision about where
road has to be placed in the level of
disruption or how
schools are paid from property
taxes, uh, that are local,
um,
you have self perpetuating system
is where the, the rich become
more advantaged in the poor,
become more disadvantaged over time. Um,
that wasn't necessarily racial though.
That was rich versus poor.
Well,
but the point is that what if
that correlates and you know,
there might be rich versus
poor. There might, it might
be male versus female.
I don't think it's the case that
we've gotten rid of all oppression.
And I just think that that would
be silly to suggest and it's not,
it's important that we not lose sight
that because our progressive's at the
moment are terrible that
we couldn't steal man.
That point if that was in our
interest in my intention is to do so.
That said there isn't enough oppression
to explain all of the phenomena that
we're seeing.
So I go to the very simple example
of top hundred chess players.
One of them is female.
Now that cannot be in my estimation,
likely caused by the law. Is oppression
encoded into the rules of chess?
Is it because you know chess is is sort
of cryptically male and that if we,
if we did it with Barbie dolls or or,
or,
or some other body positive female thing,
that girls would suddenly
become 50 50 I don't know.
I think it's unlikely to imagine that.
I don't think that it would have to be
one versus 99 and maybe it's 20 versus 80
or 40 versus 60 who knows?
But it's unlikely that it's
100% structural oppression.
Like one of my jokes is and
depression and online anonymous chest.
Yeah.
Cause it's just like it's all day.
Well,
so you have a situation where my,
my team guessed wrong. We thought
if we could get rid of red lining,
if we could get rid of literacy tests,
if we could get rid of all of the things
that were holding people back that were
just nakedly ridiculous,
that we would have this
much more even society.
And while there's still
more work to be done,
I would say that
preliminary indications are,
is that that solves some of the problem.
But it didn't solve as much of
the problem as we were hoping.
So now you have two
very difficult choices.
Do you decide that really the problem is,
is that the oppression is super
cryptic and it's much, you know, it's,
it's much worse than anyone imagines.
But that's why you're policing
microaggressions or do you decide, Huh,
I wonder if there are other factors.
And that's kind of disturbing and I'm
scared to even consider that question.
And that's,
that's the choice that the progressives
and the lefties have have faced.
Can I take it to a slightly
less heady place perhaps,
which is, I get you on that,
on the intellectual level,
but I think there's just a lazy,
it's just lazy thinking for young people.
It's just lazy to think the
system's rigged against you.
It's just lazy to think they're coming
after you because of your gender or your
sexuality or your color or,
well,
most of the aiming after you because of
your age. But it's, but it's empowering.
In other words,
it's empowering to these people to
think the whole systems against me,
I'm going to destroy it.
So it's like,
it just an easy answer as opposed to
clean up your room and get your shit
together. Yeah. When we had that,
by the way, it was tremendous
fun having Jordan and Ben, uh,
on the show did that. Um, but I
pushed back on that, which is no,
there really is an issue, particularly
intergenerationally a lot of these people,
if I take the standard child
rearing house where somebody,
you know,
at age 26 wants to propose to
somebody at age 24 and say,
Hey, I, you know,
I've got enough means to have a house
and we can have a few kids and you can
take off work for for a few years to,
to raise them with kids
with the most demanding.
That's very hard to do at the moment.
The labor market needs
to get much tighter.
We need to have employers writhing in
pain before that becomes possible again,
and I support making the labor market
tighter in order to redistribute some of
the wealth using market
mechanisms to people who need
to start their lives and
to become homeowners and to
have a stake in the system.
And we made a huge mistake in my opinion,
not understanding that when it's so
difficult to start a life in your 20s that
feels adult,
that those people are now pissed as hell.
And rightfully so because we're not
really hearing them. So I think that the,
the one that is most important to
me is that we missed the boat on
intergenerational oppression.
I think that one really feels salient.
Now. There are other things having
to do with, with race and gender,
um, which we have to get to.
And I'm not gonna pretend that,
I don't think that there are problems
in those areas. They're very, very,
very clearly are, but there isn't
enough problem at the moment.
I mean,
we have so many opportunities with a
world crying out for diversity that,
um, you know, we have,
we have to be looking how much of this
is solvable by going after oppression and
how much are we having to invent,
invent oppressions in order to avoid
looking at more disturbing questions.
And I think that what's
going on is that the,
our betters in the institutional
world have already decided that anyone
searching for explanations that
are not oppression based, uh,
and things that can't be cured
with diversity is a bad person.
And that's what's so disturbing.
Let me ask you something just on a kind
of personal note that we've talked a
little bit about privately that as a
guy that came from the institutions that
has plenty of friends and
colleagues in the institutions,
I mean you talk about all this
stuff and it in a certain way,
there's a level of kind of kissing that
goodbye, right? I mean at some level by,
by being here and calling
these things out constantly.
And I liken that to I forward you emails
probably every day now from people from
a zillion walks of life. I mean, you know,
high school teachers to choreographers
to lighting people to all scared,
scared of the exact same
thing that you're describing.
They are seeing this photo diversity come
down on them and certain people now by
their gender,
usually male by their skin color,
usually white and all of these other
things are realizing their careers or
coming to an end that they are afraid
that their future no longer works,
the things that they believed
in no longer work. Um,
so first I just want to know
just you personally like it,
that is a real shift for you.
It has to be right.
I don't even know if you want to do
this publicly, but I'm, no, I know.
Let me see if I,
if I even
understand that we are,
let's talk about what it is that we
learn when we do shows and we meet people
afterwards. Here's what we know that
nobody else in my opinion knows.
We know that people are terrified.
Yeah.
The people who are coming to these shows
are saying, thank you for speaking out.
I'm almost ready to say something at work,
but I'm fear that I'll lose
my job and my livelihood.
And I've got two kids at home.
And by the way, it's often things
like, I believe in low taxes. It's not,
you know what I mean? With God, it's,
it's like it's nothing I
believe in free speech. Yeah.
I think maybe James Damore
was, was railroaded. Oh my God.
But he's James Damore. He's
that. He's that tech Bro.
That's bro on the end of anything.
But also the idea that group,
the bro report, it's like, okay,
now we don't have to take it seriously.
But also him as tech bro in praying
that he's like this frat boy, like,
like cocky as well. This is
the most do mujer word. Yeah,
this is the most, no, he's like, yeah,
I think he's openly on the spectrum,
right? He, he's a, he's a total,
he's the shyest. I mean really in all
the shows I've done, I don't have any,
how many hundreds of interviews I've done.
He's the only guests that I felt I needed
to spend probably a half hour in the
green room just chatting with them
to get comfortable enough to talk.
This was not a bro who wants
to get in there and grow it up.
But this is the fun part. Yeah. Like I
think Bernie Bros were totally, you know,
it was basically an invention
that institutional voice is dying because
it's so funny and I think that this,
cause it's so ludicrous at this point.
The thing is,
you and I happen to have really good
information about how many people are
scared.
And we also know that the reason that
they're scared is that a tiny number of
people who hold these very
extreme positions have found
their way into the high
leverage seats. If you're sitting on the
editorial board of the New York Times,
that's a high leverage cedar. If you're
a columnist, that's a high leverage seat,
or if you're in the admissions office or
if you're in human resources or if you
are, you know, uh, a judge or a lawmaker.
And so people are seeking out these high
leverage positions if they hold very
radical perspectives, which has to
do with alternative logic. I mean,
I think,
I want to say very clearly that the
real reason that I'm so dead set against
this is that people can't be trusted with
this level of epistemic inconsistency.
And I've referred to this as
the alternative logic network,
and I just want to say one or two things
from a mathematician's perspective.
You asked me like how I see this
from a, from a math, but yeah,
give me a little math for God's sake.
There's a principle called the principle
of explosion and it says roughly that
from a contradiction
you can deduce anything,
smuggle one contradiction
through airport security.
And on the other side you can come
up with anything. Two equals seven,
two equals a chicken. Um, you know,
the United States doesn't exist.
And so this is where scientists get
very persnickety about somebody saying,
oh, come on, just let us tweak what we
say about biology a little bit. It's like,
no, there will be no tweaking of logic
itself. We are not going to allow you,
if we can avoid to smuggle one structural
contradiction in because once you get
one in, it's all over. This is, this
has to do with the unity of nature.
I don't want biology to give me many
of the results that it gives me.
Tough biology is what it is.
I don't have the right to say,
uh, you know, let's say
microcephaly. Small heads, uh,
has no effect on intelligence or that
people with down syndrome are just as
capable as anybody else because
it's not true. I want it to be true,
but my wanting it to be true
doesn't have that effect.
And if I start making those adulterations,
then the whole thing falls apart.
So this is sort of where you and your
brother Brett and, and your sister in law,
Heather and many other pejorative and a
bunch of other people have been saying
that that's the fear that if the
gender studies stuff and all of this
progressive, then you ask
Jack gets into science. We,
we literally blow apart all the progress,
all the real progress.
We'll never make sense.
You can actually make progress on the
male female stuff if you're pretending
that males and females or
both simultaneously totally
different and totally the
same. Yeah. Right?
And you have to pretend both in order
to get this new version of progressivism
to work. So you're literally
smuggling in a contradiction.
So if you say, look, we really
need a diverse workplace, um,
let's say between men and women.
And we noticed that in this particular
occupation, it's 80, 20, um,
and that has to do only with oppression
because otherwise it would be 50, 50.
Well,
what you've just done is you've said,
we know that there's no cognitive
difference between males and females, um,
because we've just assigned all of
the difference to oppression, right?
Because it would be exactly equal. But
if you allow males and females to, to,
um,
to coexist,
you're going to get this huge bonanza
because now you're going to have
intellectual diversity.
Now there,
there's actually something very clever
and very important to say that has to do
with the kind of fishers,
uh,
notion of equivalence of males and
females in terms of fitness strategies.
Um,
so there is a kind of equivalent,
but when you destroy the true
biological understanding of the,
of why males and females have the same
expected return is fitness strategies in
favor of this dime store nonsense,
you actually destroy the
ability to correct for
imbalances. And so we're, we're,
and Heather and I come down,
um,
is that we say in your
rush to build utopia,
you're going to destroy everything
that we've done and you can't take the
shortcut.
That's really what's important.
The intellectually these
shortcuts will eventually
cause the system to collapse.
And so it's not that were not sympathetic
with the idea that we'd love to see
more, more female programmers,
but let's figure out,
and this is actually what
Dimauro was focused on.
Like what changes can we make in order to,
you know,
respect the biology and make this work?
And so I, I, I think that that's what's,
what's so confusing is that
this push to assign so much,
um,
to what is essentially an intellectual
universe of pure contradiction is what's
offending many people who
consider themselves progressives,
which is like w I think
absolutely we're in the row,
we progressive's are in the right.
But you have to do it honestly.
You can't just cheat and pretend
things that you wished to be true and,
and close your eyes and put your
fingers in your ears and say, ah,
I'm not going to listen
to data and analysis.
But do you see any people on the left
besides you guys trying to fix this thing?
Well, this, yes, but, but
they're scared. You see,
this is what's so terrifying about
these current fake progressive's is,
is that they're just scary
people. They, they, they say, oh,
we need more empathy and then
what are they interested in?
Are they interested in the notion
of progress or justice? Well,
justice is all about
sticking it to somebody.
Like you have something that
belongs to this other person,
but progress is just like, let's make
things better. And hopefully, um,
you know, where there is injustice,
we can, we can identify a bad guy,
but where there is no injustice
and it's just somebody out of luck.
You're just trying to
try to raise people up.
I want to say one other thing that I
realized I forgot to say somewhere else.
Yeah.
Dana Boyd brought up a very interesting
issue which she called strategic silence
and the idea which isn't a bad one and
initially is that if somebody should not
have their voice amplified,
let's imagine that you have a manifesto
and you decide that you're going to kill
30 people.
Um,
and in the desire to figure out what the
motivation is that you're going to have
your manifesto broadcast
all over the world.
So the UNI bomber didn't kill
30, but he killed a bunch, uh,
killed a few people and names and people
and his manifesto was read widely.
So strategic silence is the idea that
reporters should not be played or used and
they should be silent
about certain things.
I think that what she did not realize is
that this much strategic silence cannot
function in an intelligent,
open society.
People are simply to mute in the press
about all sorts of things that the rest
of us have a very legitimate
interest in knowing.
And if you're going to
be strategically silent,
you should be sharing the idea that the
policy of this paper is that it doesn't
look at motive on individual instances
unless the constitutes a pattern.
But like if you take terrorists killings
when somebody reports, you know,
10 people were killed today and the
attacker said something religious in a
foreign language at the end,
you're not helping things.
You're creating a belief that there is
some kind of conspiracy and we don't know
what that's about. Is it an honest desire
to protect our vulnerable communities,
in which case many of us would be
supportive or is it because the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia,
uh,
has some relationship with our government
that may be strategic that we will
want more information about? Is that, is
that a special favor to a foreign power?
I don't know what that is,
but what I do know is that if people are
dying and that there's a motive that's
linking multiple killings,
for example,
you can't afford strategic silence and
pretend that this thing just doesn't
exist.
I think that that's partially where this,
uh, our overlords in the
institutional class are so far off,
is that they're not realizing that
there's no possible way to get rid of t to
get away with this level
of strategic silence.
And that's what created Donald Trump is
that he was willing to break strategic
silence everywhere and people were
willing to say, look, he may be crazy.
He may be immoral,
but at least he's not under the thumb
of whatever this thing is. Right.
But they're crazy. And Mro, he's
just showing us his crazy anymore.
I think that if I'm allowed to be mean,
I think that's the way the average Trump
voter felt. They're crazy and a moral,
these people, I felt somebody is probably
crazy and, but he's doing it. Okay.
I just don't like being lied
to in, in terms that, uh,
a stupid child would never
accept because these lies,
I need better lies. No, I do.
This is what I talk about.
Adult level fiction.
Are you talking about the lies of the
nature of the gate institutions or are you
talking about the rise of Trump
and of the gated institution there?
I understand that you want to not create
an incentive structure so that people
murder people so that they can
get their message out and amplify.
That makes good sense to me.
And when we get to the point
where this thing is big enough,
we may have to consider all of the
issues that the traditional media had to
consider. However, what is
absolutely not acceptable,
nobody from the State Department has ever
contacted any one of us and said, hey,
I'm a little bit worried, uh,
as to what you guys are doing.
Do you understand how this fits
in? Can you come in? Uh, you know,
we understand that you guys are,
are trying to do good, but let,
let us tell you what you s objectives are.
I've never been a part of any
conversation like this, uh,
in the last 20 years,
right?
Voc Salata buzzfeed things were so
dangerous and yet nobody's getting
radicalized in the name of Vera
client's time. Well, but you know,
we're also d radical.
Most of us are.
Most of us are patriotic and I will
definitely tailor some of what I say,
uh, to national interests if I'm aware
of what those national interests are.
But if you're not contacting
us and then you're smearing us,
then that's your only means of control.
You're not talking about a free society,
you're talking about a Potemkin democracy.
And I'm not going to participate
in your Potemkin democracy,
either have the conversation or be
prepared that nobody's going to obey your
strategic silence and you
can get rid of all of us,
but you're not going to get rid of the
number of people are going to take our
seats and the more force
you use to get rid of us,
the more you're going to radicalize
people in the name of liberty.
And I think that,
you know,
this is very important that this is really
a war over sensemaking and we have a
right to be,
I mean I wanna I want to state
this rather emphatically,
this idea of d platforming,
sensible,
rational people who are smarter than the
people who are being platform to where
more moral,
more decent and saying,
well you can't come in because you're
not part of the narrative agreement.
That's how you get something like the
French revolution. And so if you want to,
if you want to say thank you to things
like the Ruben report, we are taking this,
the pressure off of this system.
You are alive so transparently about so
many things that no sane or smart person
as an adult can believe.
And thank God there's some place
where people can come and say,
I thought I was losing my mind.
And then here you guys are,
and it's clear that you're not radical.
You're not mean spirited, you're not bad,
bad hearted.
There's no shortage of PhDs in our system.
There's no shortage. You know, Comedians
as an alternate intellectual universe,
you guys lost the plot in
the institutional space.
Why don't you come out to the
comedy store? Why, why, why,
why don't you come out at for dinner, uh,
the, you know, the next time we have it,
why didn't you call us into
Washington and say, look,
here's what our strategic
objectives. And then we'll say, okay,
you can't lie that much to people,
but what you can do is you can present
the truth in different ways and stop
making everyone feel like they're
being gaslit. All right, so here's what
I do. I think we've done probably about
an hour or so right now. Maybe an hour 10.
We're going to do about an hour and
a half total, just the two of us.
Then we want you guys in on this.
So patrion.com/ruben report
and whatever level you're at,
we're going to take your
question. So jump in on that. Um,
all this being said, do you think, I think
perhaps that we're
winning and I say winning.
I've been floating this idea
for a couple months now,
and it's partly because of what I'm
seeing out there with Jordan and when I've
been saying it to the audiences,
I always say it with the kind
of tongue in cheek, you know,
I think maybe we're starting to win guys,
and 3000 people cheer at once because
they haven't heard that before.
They haven't been around a huge
group of people where they can go.
These people are all sorts of different,
I don't know any of these people,
but we're kind of in on this together now.
Jordan always brings up the point often
in his talks that it's not about winning
per se,
because if this was a marriage,
you don't want to beat your wife in an
argument because then you're just married
to a loser. You want to get to a place
where you can both maybe have one in lost.
Maybe you won the argument,
but there was a lesson learned.
That's the type of
winning I'm talking about.
I suspect that they now think we are such
a huge threat for all the reasons that
you've just laid out,
that they're going after us in crazy ways.
That to me shows we're winning.
When I saw the veracity of the,
of the pieces that came out
after this lovely report here,
uh, I thought, wow, we're actually
bigger than these guys now.
I don't have hundreds of millions
of dollars behind me like vox does.
I've got patrons and super chat money,
you know, and it's like we're doing,
what you referred to before
is this sort of slim thing,
which is really cool right now.
And there's reasons that it's really
strong right now and maybe, yeah,
we'll all grow ferocity. That do
you mean the veracity of the for us?
I think I meant the veracity.
Okay. That these are not,
these are not very truthful reports.
Well, I meant the, that they,
there were so many of them.
Oh, okay. Wait, give me those
two definitions there. What
do I do? What did I say?
It doesn't matter. Um,
this is why I shouldn't be
interviewing smarter people. No,
I don't know. Maybe I'm getting it
wrong. Yeah. So the um, but there's,
there's a signal being read by
these people. Like holy cow,
they've got all this money and
they've got all this power. Yeah.
I've been tricked my rule in general.
I need a dictionary when I'm dealing with,
with, with, with the, with
the intelligence community.
So whenever you're talking
about something sensitive,
you should clump around because they
don't like to be surprised is what I'm
talking about. Immigration and
stuff. I try to make a lot of noise.
I tried to make a lot of noise.
This, this alternative network. Um,
and the good part of it, which is what
I'm focused on, I'm not talking about,
I don't know, whatever Richard Spencer
is saying to baked Alaska cause who, who,
who gives a shit. Yeah. Um,
the good part of this network has
been making a ton of noise. Hey,
this is important. People are
listening. The events, you know,
our large people are fanatical
and they're normal people.
Um,
we are winning at some level,
but we are losing,
we're not winning quickly enough and clean
enough. Well, that's what I always say.
What do I say to you every week? We're
not moving fast enough. Well, okay,
but this thing has its own pace.
So somehow when the gated institutional
narrative issues or report that tries to
take you all out, um, next
time guys, first of all,
assigned somebody better than Rebecca
because she just doesn't have the chops
yet. Maybe, maybe in five years
if you're going to come for us,
come loaded for bear and do
it intellectually correct. Um,
my concern is, is that the next moves
are going to be highly personal.
Like how do we take out, you
know, you saw this thing with
Rogan talking about white
farmers in Africa. You know,
Rogan says some crazy stuff on his show.
I'm not sure whether what
he said was crazy or not,
cause I haven't looked at this,
but I have no doubt that Joe holds
some positions that are, that are off.
I certainly hold positions that are often,
when I find them,
I try to correct them,
but suddenly the litany of people going
after him as if he's a racist because he
even talked about this.
Well, yes. And you know,
Rebecca Lewis is very adamant that we
shouldn't have gotten angry at Elan Musk
for smoking dope. Uh, on the show.
We should have gotten angry that a Elon
Musk went on Joe Rogan because he gave a
platform to James Moore and
Jordan Peterson. Jordan. I mean,
doesn't that tell you everything?
This kind of bananas a inside of
this tiny little bubble stuff,
um,
they're going to get more sophisticated.
So just thinking about it as a video game,
um,
we've been playing with like lots of
low level orks on level zero and, okay.
So then things got ratcheted up.
This isn't terribly serious.
It's going to get more serious because
as the narrative outcomes to understand
just how big these channels are,
just how influential they are. Let,
let me be open about something.
Part of the theory behind
defining the Idw, uh,
has to do with my understanding of
how demography works in presidential
elections.
So one way of winning an election is
that you find a demographic that nobody
knew existed and then you speak to them
and they're large enough to sway things.
So soccer moms remember soccer moms.
Okay.
Another one of these things was Karl
Rove's discovery of the excerpt where you
have urban,
suburban something and then rural
in between suburban and rural,
there was this thing that nobody
understood called the excerpt.
And so by finding that you could
find some demographic chunk.
So both parties, uh, let me
be very clear about this.
The IDW nation is quite large.
It's people who've had
enough of low level lies.
They don't mind adult level fictions that
are in the best interests of everybody,
but they cannot put up with this
level of nonsense coming out of our
institutions and part of what's going
on inside the institutions at the
institutions have a fake public facing
front and then an internal group.
And this is how they
handle things. So like, um,
I think Danny Roderick talked about,
um,
public voice and seminar voice that as
an economist you can say certain things
to your colleagues,
but when you're talking to the public,
you have to say different things.
And unfortunately they don't even really
mirror each other too closely. Right?
And so it's okay to lie to the public.
And so when you've talked to
an economist and you say, well,
you can't possibly believe what, what, uh,
that immigration and trade or pure
positives of course not. Well,
but you just said that or you allowed your
colleague to say you stayed know well,
that's what you have to say in front of
the public because they can't follow the
analytic argument. Well, okay, that's
a, that's academic malpractice.
You're engaged in academic
malpractice when you do that. Um,
whatever you say to the public has to
be a version of what you're saying in
private or you're engaged in
some kind of Potemkin statecraft.
And if the idea is that we can't have
a country, because actually if you,
if you took the constitution seriously,
it wouldn't work.
Then we have to talk about,
okay,
well what are we going to do that would
work that, that would actually be viable.
But right now what we have
is we have a bunch of, um,
not very intelligent adults
who are not very honest,
who are sitting in the most important
chairs telling us that we're all idiots
and world deplorable across
this political spectrum.
And that's not going to work and
that we are going to win that battle.
So for all the people that at
every Q and a that I do anywhere,
either with Jordan or at the standup
shows that I'm doing are we got,
I think basically this question, we, we
did a little IDW, is it pretty awesome?
Actually, within a day we set up
an IDW, there's an IDW group now,
which they're springing
up all over the place.
This one sprung up in New York City. We
did a, a room down on Bleecker street,
300 people standing room only. We
did it for free. They, you know,
whatever we grifters, I know it's such
grifters you did it for free. Uh, but,
but putting that aside, uh, the question
that consistently comes up is, okay,
we get all this people go, you know, get,
all the ideas were onboard and we like
what you're doing. We want to help.
We're ready to, you know, show our faces
and, and be part of this whole thing.
We know there's a technological answer.
How is it that you morons
haven't come up with it yet?
There's some version of that,
like aren't you guys the ones
supposed to be doing all right?
Well you and I have been talking
and working on this in various ways.
Let's just be honest about this.
We haven't known when the right time
is because the investment in trying to
rebuild the infrastructure
and then there's a question
about how are you going,
you know,
if on the other side of this thing,
there really is a collaboration between
technology, intelligence and media. Uh,
it doesn't make sense to build the system
only to have it torn down by people
with special access, um, in a non
competitive non-market kind of a way.
But make no mistake,
um,
this is a viable concept.
I think it's going to happen.
I think it's important that
it happened before 2020. Um,
and the key,
you know,
people should know that there's a
lot of billionaire interest in this.
There's a lot,
and I don't mean one person.
I mean several billionaires
are sniffing around this. Um,
and I think Ben Shapiro just
got to this show on Fox.
I'll be on this Friday. Okay. So, uh,
this is going to heat up.
And I think what's really important is
to watch what happens to data and society
as this particular, um, report, uh,
finds its course.
Because if what we see is
that the institutions agreed
to cite this because it's
a big serious report in a pdf file.
Um,
then that's going to tell us a lot
about how far the institutions are gone.
And I,
you and I differ somewhat where I believe
I want to rebuild the institutions
because I think it's a shame to,
we've got some bad hermit crabs
and some perfectly good shells.
I don't want to crack the shells
just to get it. The hermit crabs.
I think your feeling is,
is that things are so rotten that it
might be better starting from scratch.
Well,
I feel that mostly about the Democrats.
I don't feel that about our institutions,
so I don't feel that about our academic
institutions and things of that nature.
I think those things, I agree.
I want to keep that Shell.
Let's get rid of the bad crabs that are
in there. Fine. Um, but the Democrats,
I think it's basically through and
through at this point, but maybe not. And,
and I would be, believe
me, if the day comes,
and I have to eat crow on that one because
they came back to sanity and there's
suddenly a new JFK and a Daniel Patrick
Moynihan and I will gladly eat crow and
mia culpa,
the whole Shebang.
I think one of the big questions is how do
we save the, uh, you know, I think I've,
I've asked before, does this come down
to the University of Chicago or the,
are they the only ones who
are holding the line, uh,
on the enlightenment standards?
But I think one of the things
we should be doing in the,
in the academic institutions is having
debates where two departments are
studying the exact same
thing like gender and sex,
uh, in biology departments and gender,
women's studies departments, uh,
or for example, the wage gap where you
have the economists version of this.
And then you have like, let's say the
women's studies version of this. Um,
we should be holding debates to
bring about the unity of knowledge.
And so we understand where are we divided
if you have two different academic
standards,
uh,
I think people would be shocked if they
looked at the article which introduced
the concept I think of white
privilege and maybe mail,
which was like unpacking the
knapsack coming out of Wellesley.
If they looked at the, that's where
a lot of this stuff was born. Right?
That very piece, well that some of it was
born in that piece. Some of it was born,
I think it a woman's name is
professor Crenshaw at Ucla.
The intersectionality,
which originally had a very
different flavor than what we call it
intersectionality today. Um, it's
very important to look at the,
at the genesis of these ideas and to
look what is their academic pedigree.
And you know,
they're not all terrible ideas,
but a lot of them are just puristics
that are fighting things that are much
farther down in the stack.
And it's not tamale
anybody. You'll look if, if,
if the wage gap is really 25 cents,
I want to know,
but I don't trust that
the wage gap is 25 cents.
If somebody refuses to control
for things like, you know,
the choice of what field they get,
their training or how much kin
work they're doing. And you know,
as I've said on this program before,
if the problem is, is that uh,
too much kin work is falling to
females and that this is uncompensated,
we may have to do something which
this real labor that is being done
for society in monetary terms,
women may need to get paid more,
you know,
but let's make the arguments honestly,
and let's stop lying about everything
where if you don't sign up for the idea
that there's a 25 cent wage gap,
um,
which has no known source
other than oppression, uh,
that you need to be deeply
informed and not be able to learn,
earn a living because your, your views
are beyond the pale. That's, that's,
that's moronic.
I think that's a break right there.
That was pretty sad. You
want to do something so you
finally focused, you know,
I do all the shows with you and I'm
like, ah, what is he saying? Really?
I want to get back to the tits for and
Thall Magic Square and large exceptional
lead groups or whatever the chaff. I
really only did that just so in the title.
We could put tits,
Freud and Dorcas tits on youtube plays.
We never saw what happened
with that experiment.
Whether it got a higher view
camp. Oh, I should check him
out. I have no idea. Well,
you never know how youtube is manipulating
these things. All right people,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to take literally
one two minute break. We
are going to pour whiskey.
You always say that is going to be one
or two. Do you have to pee this time?
Probably.
All right,
well then depending on how long
Dr Eric Weinstein has to urinate,
that will be the length of the break.
We're gonna pour some whiskey on the
rocks and then we're going to take some
questions.
So patrion.com/ruben report,
we're going to give you guys
preferential treatment. Uh,
you can jump in on super chat as well. Oh.
And by the way, I'm the, on October 5th,
I am going to be at wise guys in Utah,
a comedy doing about an hour of comedy
and there will be a special guest from
the intellectual dark web.
It's a big one.
I don't want to say who
you've joined me. Pq, can you,
I'm going to ask for a plug for my,
a new youtube channel.
And you're doing the youtube and I'm
on Instagram because I'm getting,
I want to diversify so that if I get
kicked off of Twitter for something,
I'm not completely dependent on that
place is sort of depressing. So they did,
they put out this alternative
influencer network about youtubers.
You've put up at least three
videos. Yeah. You didn't get on.
I'm a major youtube or man Erickson,
the a on the youtube. What is it?
Just a slash Eric r Weinstein or
how do you know what it is? I,
I actually will fire.
We're going to find it.
We're going to comment on the
video after the livestream. Ah,
give us like two minutes. Whiskey your
questions. patrion.com/rubin report.
Uh,
we'll be right back.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
wow.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
wow.
[inaudible]
Huh?
All right guys. We are
back. We've got whiskey.
First off chairs my friend.
Cheers.
Let's see what happens because
of all the guff that, uh,
Ilan took when he went on Rogen your shot
telling everybody this is not actually
whiskey. It's, it's IOWASCA. It's
Iowasca that's right on the rocks.
You wouldn't smoke weed on
camera with you. Pardon me?
You wouldn't smoke weed on camera
with you? Never. Alright, here we go.
So real quick, uh, we're gonna take
questions from a patriotic people first.
So Reuben, select
patrion.com/rubin report. Uh,
we've got a whole bunch
of questions already. Uh,
we'll do some stuff on super chat as well.
I will be at wiseguys in Salt
Lake City on October 5th,
Dave ruben.com/events and the links
in the description right down below.
All right.
What us normies get is that the very
personal attacks against famous people are
a warning to the normies. Not to step
out of line. Do you agree with this?
Absolutely. Yeah. That's what I've
been pushing for a while. Well,
this in terms of this network
diagram, um, I just, you know,
so this guy,
Cody Wilson,
who had the three d printable
guns defense distributed.
So I follow him on Twitter and
there was just an ominous tweet,
which is like Cody Wilson is
followed by the following accounts.
Well,
I,
I'd follow Adolf Hitler if you were
on Twitter to know what he's thinking.
I mean the fact that you follow somebody,
if that's evidence of your moral
turpitude and how base and file you are.
I mean, for God's sakes, if I was at war,
I would tune into my enemies broadcasts.
You can't tell anything from that.
So this is part of the scare tactics and
I think that those of us who are trying
to be the advanced guard and have
to make fun of this. Yeah. So yes,
you're, they are trying to scare you
that if you listened to these people,
you will be radicalized,
you will be unemployable.
And,
um,
let us take the first few
steps and make fun of this.
And then it would be great if you
followed in behind and made fun of us,
made fun of not us, but well they
can make fun of us. That's fine.
But they certainly do. But yeah, that
make fun of this mania about saying, well,
so and so talked to so and so talked to.
So and so.
And I just want to say one thing about
this I haven't gotten to yet. Yeah.
The whole concept of a safe space is
not about people being triggered that I
think is false. I think what it
is is about safety for narratives.
And so if you have a nonsensical
narrative as you do in cult,
that narrative cannot survive
direct contact with outsiders.
And so if you think about it,
it's funny that the institutions are
actually a cult like network that aren't
confident enough of their
opinions. I mean, look,
I've never taken any kind
of class in my life. Uh,
I want to tell people that their
calculation, the calculation of CPI, um,
on a cost of living a basis with
changing preferences is completely wrong.
And I know how to do it. And my wife
knows how to do it. And so far as I know,
nobody else knows how to do it.
And if you want to come at me and say,
that's nonsense and this is the,
the ratings of an amateur, uh,
name the time and the place.
I'll show up at any ECON department
and make that argument that kind of a,
a narrative,
um,
which is that you have to have a secret
group of people adjusting the CPI. Um,
because so much is indexed to CPI.
So billions of dollars change hands when
you change the calculation of CPI. Uh,
that's a nonsensical statement.
And so you need a safe space that says
only the experts can understand this.
That's the same thing that we're
seeing with so many of our positions,
which is that people imagine,
um,
that the safe space is about not wanting
to hurt people's feelings. No, no, no.
It's about not wanting,
uh,
these nonsensical narratives to come
into contact with intelligent critics.
And I think that people have to understand
that you're being warned away from
PhDs, from, uh,
other alternative intellectuals who have
a lot to say. Like Noam Chomsky, um,
because the narratives
are being protected.
So a couple of people have
asked me questions like
this that I've gotten before
just now, but I did get it here. So I'm
just going to sort of paraphrase it.
I think you saw the moment when I had
Shapiro on a couple of weeks ago and we
got into the gay cake thing again.
He said he would not bake me a
cake for my anniversary party.
He said he may not even come to
my anniversary party. And I said,
my hope is that if we can remain friends
for 50 years, I can move you on this.
Now I understand that I cannot be
friends with Ben exactly the same way.
I can be friends with you
because of that particular issue.
We can be friends and friendly and,
and allies in a lot of ways. But we,
there's a separation there for sure.
But I do consider him a friend who I
have differences with and that's okay.
And I want to respect his differences
and he's not trying to take away my
marriage or jail me or take away my things
as people keep telling me he's trying
to do. I'm curious what you
just thought of that exchange,
just as watching somebody talk about
morals and sin and how that's related to
your ability to be friends with someone.
Yeah,
I've got a terrible view on this.
That's why I ask.
Um,
I don't know,
I think Ben is actually being very
genuine in terms of the analytics of it,
but are you don't sense that he's got,
I think it's a very formal homophobia as
opposed to a visceral homea homophobia.
Like, okay, there's some, uh,
there's some passage in the,
in the Torah that says this is not good.
And so it says,
thou shall not lie with a man
as you would a woman basically.
But I don't lie with women that way,
so it's all good. You know what I mean?
Let's not make a big deal in.
Yeah. Um, okay, so focus the, uh,
so I think that Ben is actually
being reasonable and you know,
in the same way that as a,
as a guy with a,
a fair number of clothes,
a gay male friends,
I know that there are some parties that
you guys feel comfortable inviting me to
and other parties that you wouldn't
feel comfortable inviting me to.
I'm not sure what you mean. Not Go higher
than me. I'm not having those parties.
You can come to any of my parties.
Somebody whose name will not be known,
would not be known to your
audience. Once said to me, um,
if it's boys soup, uh, and there
are a lot of twinks running around,
you're not going to be the one getting
the invitation and I hope you're okay
with it. So that would be a
kind of discrimination that
would be for my benefit.
And I think that,
you know,
this is what happens when Ben brings
his own food to the dinner party you're
having,
he's trying to say,
how do I integrate into your life in
a way that allows me to keep my modern
Orthodox position?
And I actually really valued,
I is honesty and I, and I, and I
just, I want to get something across.
And Ben's defense, which is, yeah,
it does seem kind of backward.
And on the other hand it
seemed kind of awesome. Um,
which was that he was owning
that this was a discomfort.
There was no real bar in my opinion,
to the depth of your friendship and
he's just going to be formal about it.
Yeah. By the way, if you hang
around with Orthodox Jews, they,
there's a lot of this,
they're very formal about rules and
they're also very adept at getting around
them.
And so this is exactly what I expect
from an Orthodox Jew is that he is open
minded in some ways.
He's,
I think he's very progressive on this
front and he's going to be upfront,
like formally, I can't
do these things. Uh,
but it's very similar to when I
have Muslim friends in, you know,
I have Turkish friends and stumble
and you're having an fs beer and um,
then you say, hey, you know,
isn't it strange that you're a Muslim and
you're having this beer? And they said,
you know, I really shouldn't. And they put
the beer down for the rest of the meal.
Or in India you talk about people being
confirmed, bachelors that are gay,
just give people their formal out.
Uh,
and that's the way that they're dealing
with their form of formal homophobia.
I don't think it's very deep. Yeah. And I
just thought all these people were like,
oh, she Reuben such a sellout. He's
letting, he's sitting there with someone,
tells him he's a sinner and it's like,
well then when they're ready
to come to the adult table,
we'll welcome them
there. We all right. Uh,
well we answered it.
You answered a couple of,
there's a lot about just like how can
a business be built around this? Um,
okay.
Eric, I'd love to see you have a
discussion with the free market.
Economists like Brian Kaplan. Would you
be interested in something like that?
I've had Brian Kaplan on the
show. He's, yeah, he's an
endcap guy. I really, I mean,
I like those ideas. I just liked
the intellectual place that those,
I didn't know you'd be happy to do
that. Right. I think so. Yeah. Why not,
right. Talk to Tyler Cowen a lot in
Tyler and I disagree on some stuff,
but um, you know, just
as people should know,
the universe of smart generative people
is so small that we don't usually screen
each other on ideology.
We're just so happy to,
to meet somebody who's
thinking deeply and his open
or just basically will act in good
faith. And then it's like, oh,
you think differently. Okay.
It's all good. I didn't know
about this, maybe you did,
but how do you feel about the nation of
Hungary proposing to ban gender studies
as a discipline at their universities?
Had you heard about this?
No. Um, I mean I think
it's very important to,
I would not ban gender studies. I think I
would do what I just said, which is, uh,
make sure that you have a uniform
standard of scholarship and not, um,
a form of scholarship that
is friendly to activism.
You have to make sure that
activist scholarship, uh,
is recognized as something
other than pure inquiry. I mean,
are you capable of disseminating a,
finding that you're very upset to find
that that's a prerequisite for having
professorial privileges, uh, in
terms of tenure and academic freedom?
I suspect there's very
little of that these days.
People that truly go in without any
sciences, there's tons of it. Yeah.
Yeah. And you know, this is my,
my basic take on the universities is
the heart and soul of the great research
universities.
It's hard core disciplines.
We've done much more in those
disciplines than anybody else.
And so who are you and get out of my
lab, uh, is an important principle.
And as long as we have something that
keeps bad scholarship from getting in,
from, you know, bringing
the principle of explosion,
as we talked about before
into the sciences, um,
we should start exporting a scientific
notions of rigor and we should be holding
debates between disciplines to make sure
that everything is other piece rather
than saying, okay, well you have no
wage gap and you have a wage gap.
We don't even know if it's
the same word. Um, so I,
I think that it's a bad move.
Instead,
what we should do is we should make sure
that all of these fee, and by the way,
if gender studies has figured out some
things that the biologists don't know,
we have to take our lumps in
biology. It's not, it's not a,
there's no fix in that game.
Do you have any recommendations for having
a more s epistemological? The honest,
yeah,
responsible conversation.
I think that the anti is much higher
than people imagine that one of the w you
know, I think about, um, I
don't know why I do this,
but I think about the old shows love
boat and fantasy island versus game of
Thrones in the Sopranos. Like the
Auntie is a lot higher these days.
We are smart and we have
long attention span,
put down love boat on my show. I have
a thing, I carry a torch for Julie.
Um, but, uh, the cruise director,
um,
I,
I think that people have to understand
that if you want to behave in a more
epistemically consistent fashion,
uh,
you're going to need to budget one or
two orders of magnitude more brain space
because most of them,
the heuristics that have been pushed out
or completely unworkable in our modern
world. And once you open up that
brain space, once you say, okay,
I'm going to follow game of Thrones for
season after season in episode after
episode, you're having a much
better time than you ever had, uh,
with shows that had to have their entire
narrative arcs concluded within 30
minutes.
And that sadly they did that on love boat,
right?
Like it's like you got an hour,
it was about we're going to do this and
we're going to wrap this thing around in
40 minutes. And there you go. Eric,
what do you think about a potential
satellite based Internet solution?
Because it seems like I SSPs are going
to start banding content over landlines.
I mean this goes to all the technological
things that people are talking about.
Well, right, so you, you tell us, uh,
how much you want to persecute us and
then you'll cause the development of a
crypto and smart contracts and satellites
and that can be free market guy.
I'm like, no, I just want people
to be happy. Free market. Okay.
Um,
is,
well, there's again,
there's a lot about that.
Is there anything to be done with social
media and funding platforms and payment
processors who are in the sensor sip
business? It's sort of the same question.
You can give me something on
that while I'm looking here.
Um,
look,
there are some very serious problems that
the major platforms are facing that we
are not facing.
And I think it's very important for us
to recognize that once you break it,
you've bought it.
So if we start our own thing,
they're going to be all
sorts of intellectual half
measures that are going to
have to happen.
Um,
so we're in a relatively luxurious
position riding on top of somebody else's
platform and they're
handling the problems.
I do think they're going to have to
be innovations. As I said earlier,
there's something I forgot to say that
it's very important that I'm just going
to shove in here.
There's this talk about whether
or not Google is biasing search.
Oh, I'm glad you're bringing this. This
is super. Let's really do this. Yeah,
we should have done this in the
first part of my bed. All right.
Google is biasing search and the
way in which they're able to say,
we don't buy a search is how they buy a
search, so need to look up m l fairness,
machine learning,
fairness.
Google has released a video and they
talk about their need to unbiased search.
That's how the bias is coming in.
This is the Google is acting,
and I think I said this in a tweet
as an incompetent ophthalmologist,
you have a very mild case,
let's say,
of a stigmatism or myopia and Google says,
oh my God,
you're suffering from some terrible,
they're sightedness in your eye.
Your eyeballs are all misshapen here.
We're going to give you the craziest,
thickest glasses you can imagine.
Now you're blind as a bat when you,
when you're putting those on.
But from their perspective,
they're helping you unbias
your bias problem. Uh, can,
can you just for people
that haven't got this,
can you explain why they think
and biasing makes sense? Sure.
It is definitely true that physics,
let's say,
used to be a much more European
dominated male activity.
It just is.
It was now it is less so now,
but it is still very often dominated
by men who are a fair of you.
Right?
There perspective is,
well that's a bias because in the past
that's what physicists looked like.
So if you do an image search,
we should be correcting for that bias.
So we're going to show you,
uh, Neil degrasse Tyson. Uh,
we're going to show you Stefan
Alexander or James Gates.
And so you know that they're showing
you African Americans and then maybe,
you know, surely, uh, what's
her name? Shirley Jackson,
a black female. And so suddenly you're
saying, well, wow, this is really crazy.
I'm doing the search on physicists and
I'm seeing all black faces or something
like this.
And so what they're doing is that
they're claiming to undo latency bias,
which is the data hasn't
caught up to the world.
That will be where things
are much more equal.
And so we've just fit you
with the prescription,
but you're looking at this and saying,
wow,
you're really biasing your data in
order to have a social justice agenda.
And so whatever's going on with Donald
Trump, he's not saying the magic words.
The question isn't to Google.
Are you biasing your data?
The question the Google is,
are you an biasing your day?
Tell me how your unbiased
in your data. And the, the,
the phrase that pays is ml fairness.
I should also say that anybody who knows
engineers within youtube and Google and
all of these things knows that
some of them are very unhappy.
And some of those very unhappy engineers
are talking about all of the ways that
they're being forced to degrade the
product and to privilege certain sources.
Like I've seen a list of rankings
of various news sources as to how
authoritative they should be.
And so the no,
no surprise,
um,
very liberal institutional medias
and gets very high rankings.
And so from their perspective,
none of this has
nothing to do with politics.
It just has to do with
biasing authoritative sources.
Well that has everything to do with
the fact that you think it's authority.
Please just open this up
so the rest of us can,
can toggle these switches because if,
if you're going to tell me, I mean I,
I know that a lot of things in the
New York Times happened to be true,
but I also know that it has a very strong
ideological bias at the moment that's
getting worse.
And so I don't feel the same way
about privileging the New York Times.
I think this is something else that
I want to talk about. There are no
authoritative sources that we can use
as baseline at the moment and it's a
little bit like having a
dollar denominated fund at
a point when the dollar is
falling or rising rapidly
relative to everything else.
If you are referencing yourself,
like Wikipedia says,
we accept authoritative sources and then
there's some activists that gets into
one of the sources that they consider
authoritative and then Wikipedia says,
okay, well we have to print this because
it occurred in an authoritative source.
That's why the danger of letting
the Sarah Johns of the world in,
in their activist role,
um,
is because we now don't know
what an authoritative sources.
I would say that there are
no authoritative sources
of an institutional nature
at the moment because all of
the institutions are scrambling.
And quite frankly, this is the one
thing that keeps me up at night.
And the whole IDW concept was an answer
to the question from where will we
reboot when this madness is over?
Like it's not going to be from,
um,
departments in universities that have
been taken over by activism or news.
Oregon's or political parties.
It's going to be from individuals.
And I think that the thing that is
most authoritative right now are the
individuals with a lot of surface
area who are pretty trustworthy.
Do you think there's a cutoff point,
uh,
for the individuals who
the good guys inside?
I'm not just talking about the average
person right now for the people that are
inside that get it,
but that are cowards right now and maybe
for good reasons that a coward better
that are acting cowardly. No, no, no.
Or that they don't afraid for
a litany of boundaries there.
I don't want to say Karen,
I'm just going to push,
but you know I'm a little more
frustrated with these people because they
privately come up.
But you know what the thing is is that
how many nights do I wake up in a cold
sweat? Like, oh no, what's going
on at, you know, it's a, it's a,
so when they come for you,
yeah. And there, you know, it's,
it's merciless and its life destroying.
So I don't think these people are cowards
take on the level of risk that you can
afford to take on.
If you've got two really young kids at
home and you're just getting by on a gig
economy thing,
don't do it.
Don't stay at some level.
Safe enough that you can meet your
obligations. But if you happen to have,
as Joe Rogan says, f you
money, uh, [inaudible]
that's not it. It needs to be more
than just the f you money people. No.
If you have a little bit of a few money,
you don't have to be,
you don't have to have
eight figures of wealth.
If you're in a position where you have
very few dependence and you know, you, uh,
you do a go pro videos, uh, and with
extreme skateboarding on weekends,
you're already taking major
risks. Get in here, help us out.
Don't be a pussy about it.
Right?
I think there's a cutoff point
though for certain people,
like once we fix things and
if you didn't get onboard,
[inaudible] are two more
Qurans private truths,
public lies.
Because the idea is you have some number
of people who are willing to go first
and then you have some people who are
willing to take on slightly less risk,
but they're really right in behind you.
But the thing is is that we need
more people evaluate your risk.
If you can afford to join us, join
us. That's the point. But look,
there are people who,
there are people who are being cowardly.
They have all the advantages in
the world and they won't step up.
Those are the ones that I'm frustrated
with. Not The average person. Yeah.
But I don't want to attack. And eyes are,
are people who are saying like, you know,
you know, but when I, if I lose my
job, how do I provide for my children?
We don't understand yet,
of course. And I'm not talking about
those people. You know, when, when, uh,
there was a,
there was a dinner we got into where
it got pretty heated because there is a
certain set of very wealthy Hollywood
people that are down with what we're doing
and they won't do it publicly. And
it's like, and I was the one that was,
it's, it's, it's what Morpheus says to
neo. He says, I'm not gonna lie to you.
Everyone who has ever faced an agent,
you know, uh, has met their end. Um,
but sooner or later somebody is going
to have to and when it's time you'll be
able to,
okay.
Well you have people who are going to
try to fight the agents first and the
least you can do is don't undermine the
people who are taking the risk in order
to sell them out to feed them to the
crowd. Right. So don't be cipher. Right.
Cause you think it gives you a little
more time or something. Right. But,
but in general,
um,
if you don't have a lot of obligations
and you've got a little bit of change in
your pocket and you don't need that
much, get in here and help. Yeah.
Uh, David, if you ever had
to have tosh 0.0 on the show,
seems like a guy who benefits from free
speech. I don't think we have tried.
I will look into that. Um, oh, I like,
I like this one for you because this is a
very Jordan Peterson question. Uh, Eric,
I have a three month old.
How do you raise a responsible,
critical thinking son in this
polarized postmodern world of bananas?
Well, first of all, do something like
Peter's give, give me some hand motions.
Little of this. No, Jordan, Jordan
on me. All right, fine. Um, you know,
I kept my son off of social media,
just introduced him on my channel. Uh,
and Zev is just opened his own his
own channel. So check that out. Um,
the thing I did was I took my children
as seriously as they deserved to be taken
as soon as they were ready.
And I was astounded really at how
quickly a smart child's mind comes online
ready to deal with things. And I
think I remember when was sandy hook,
it's over two years ago now.
It's maybe it was, there was,
it was a school shooting.
And I talked to the children about
risk extensively and they weren't that
disturbed because they had an intrinsic
sense that the odds of anything
happening in their school were quite low,
but that there is no guarantee.
And you know,
if I think back on all of the crazy
conversations I had with my two children,
a daughter and a son,
uh,
be prepared that it's not just children.
Say The darndest thing.
Children are ready for much
more adult interaction, uh,
while still being they're
adorable child like cells.
And don't be afraid if you find yourself,
uh,
in a,
in a conversation that you can't believe
you're having with a three or a four
year old. Both of those happened with
my children. I remember when I was away,
um,
I had,
I taught myself to play the Vivaldi Largo
Movement from a guitar concerto and my
daughter said, I miss you Daddy.
And she said, listen to this.
And she played it on violin. So I knew
she wasn't getting it from sheet music.
And I just thought like, okay, what
you're F you're five [inaudible] six.
I don't know. I don't remember what age
your children are going to astound you.
Take it seriously and don't
treat it as if it's adorable.
Treat it as if it's serious.
Well said.
There's a lot of Peterson
style questions here.
You want to keep going on that
whatever you want. All right. Uh,
if what Peterson has said is true,
that we're living in a 13 year old girls
reality and most of the people who want
a d platform,
the ITW are possibly emotionally stuck.
Is attacking their ideas
directly effective at all?
Or is there any value in starting an
emotional discussion that goes on a little
bit more from there?
Yeah,
well it's, we'll go from
that. I think that, um,
this is something I said at the end
of our performance in New York, uh,
on that panel. Um, if you can,
if you're in a position to love
your opponent out of their cult,
do that. You don't have to always
return costs and assume, you know,
very often you're dealing with frightened
and scared people who don't realize
that they're much more resilient
than they think. They're stronger.
The world isn't as hostile.
People form completely insane ideas
about what they're up against.
And you know, I remember, um,
my, my, my defacto uncle,
uh, Mike Brown, um,
who used to invite us onto, onto his,
his island up in Washington state,
um, I think it was a republican and
a positive. He was like the kindest,
most generous person. Uh, I could imagine.
And people who came to the island who
had very strong left of center ideas that
had this idea that somehow republicans,
we're all selfish.
I can't tell you how common that
belief and I'd have to point out,
you realize that your host is providing
everything for you and it's just the
kindest best person who give
you the shirt off his back. Uh,
is voting in a way that you would think
of is selfish because he wanted low
taxes and he believed that this was the
best way to help people out of poverty
is to give them self reliance. Try. Yeah.
I really believe that in some sense.
Um,
set an example and try to show people
that who they think they're dealing with
isn't too, they're dealing with. Um,
have you guys discussed the possibility
of this movement becoming a third
political party?
Is that actually even possible?
Not only sort of hit on this button
needs to be a third political party?
I think it should infect both political.
I think our system of selective pressures
determined by the constitution more or
less selects for two parties,
whether it's Democrats or Republicans
or the weeks come back, doesn't matter.
The key thing is that we,
we on the left need you on the right to
be responsible and you need to know you
have a party on the other side.
And I think that was the magic where Ben
Shapiro after the joint appearance came
to me and he said, you know, Eric,
the thing that I fight on
the left is these claims that
the market or society is,
is all off.
And he says,
when you come in with a highly specific
complaint about some aspect of the
market or, or an impression or
something like this, he says,
I'm absolutely willing to
listen. And I thought, wow. Um,
this is how we do it,
is that we sh the left takes out,
it's garbage on the extreme left.
The right takes should take out.
It's garbage on the extreme right.
And you'll start to see,
I think Ben,
for example,
engages in a certain amount of live
baiting that he'd love to stop.
And it's really targeted on the extreme.
It's not targeted on the center.
And I think he would come in.
So
the center and left and right,
it needs to go fight its own wings
that are polarizing everything.
But the IDW doesn't live in one
party and it's not a separate party.
What it is is an agreement about what
constitutes conversation and what
constitutes a legitimate argument.
And part of the rap against us is that
we're snowflakes and that we don't want
to talk to people who think things
that are very different from us.
In a weird way,
I think we don't want to talk to people
who have really novel ideas about what
constitutes an argument because we have
a clear idea of what constitutes and
argument and everybody's willing to
submit. Okay, you got the better of me.
You know,
I remember a particular moment where
Sam Harris got the better of me and my
first podcast with them.
Um, the key thing that,
that we don't like is when you
just make up your own logic,
you're not entitled to your own logic
and you're probably not entitled to your
own facts. And you're not entitled, uh,
to just go off on your own.
Epistemically inconsistent tangent to
get all the goodies. Once you meet some,
some of these criteria,
I think we'll talk to Moralis.
Anybody who's got a decent heart and a
desire to figure out what would generally
be seen as best for society, but it should
be, have a both the left and a right.
I'm not interested in it
becoming a third party.
I like that you call it an agreement.
I don't think I've ever heard you say
that before. I like that. Um, all right.
So we're going to take a
couple more on Reuben select.
It's patrion.com/ruben report and then
we're going to keep drinking whiskey.
Uh,
Eric,
what do you make of the metaphysical
implications of the Big Bang?
I'm not a lot. Well, give me
one more sentence on that. Sure.
Uh,
when you solve Einstein's equations,
there are two essential
singularities that you encounter.
One is the black hole singularity, um,
that you associate with a collapsing star.
And the other one is the Big Bang,
uh,
initial singularity that you associate
with the beginning of the universe.
And really in some sense what they tell
us as mathematicians and now I'm going
to take some guff for saying this,
but is that Einstein's equations aren't
the final aren't the end of the story
because they probably wouldn't
have these defects if you will.
And so there's the big bang that occurs
with respect to, you know, the, the,
the moment of last scattering or what,
however you want to think
about what we can observe. Um,
and then there's the initial singularity,
which has to do with the Einstein
equations. And in general,
you don't want to make
metaphysical inferences around
the points of your model,
which are least reliable. And so it just
for the simple 10 on this one, so if the,
so the argument would be that if it was,
if these were perfect theories,
that the big bang and basically wormholes
wouldn't, wouldn't exist. Our molds but,
but, but like black holes,
courts, chills, singularities yes.
That's what the argument is that,
that those are the signs that
you're not done yet. Got.
And so the problem is some people become
very attached to the idea that they
should be investigating those
for metaphysical implications.
But likely all your work is going to be
wiped out when a better set of equations
becomes available if you're trying to
make metaphysical meaning out of that.
So it's super tempting.
And the reason to do it would be that
you wanted to push the equations so hard
that they broke so you could find the
true ones. That doesn't bother me at all,
but don't spend too much time thinking
about something in a system pushed beyond
its domain of reliability. All
right, here we go. Two more.
Cause we got some stuff to do
tonight. Uh, I'm just a regular dude.
Other than daily exercise
of basic critical thinking.
What is the role of regular dudes like
me improving the quality of sense making
a midst the corrupted institutions
you've been discussing the regular guy,
not that fuck you money guy. First of all,
I don't, I've never met a regular dude.
My belief that everybody has something
extraordinary in them. So first of all,
stop, stop claiming you're just a regular
dude unless it's your false modesty.
And, um, and then the question is,
if you're already here asking
these questions and you're a PA,
a patron of the Rubin report,
uh,
think about yourself as already in a
tiny minority and take on some goddamn
responsibility for where you want to steer
this thing and, uh, and ask for help.
If you, you know, pick up an
order and start rowing man.
All right, one more. Um, this
is, I'm going to go to super
chat. This is Tim pulled.
Do you know Tim, by the
way? I've never met him,
although I think he's reached out to
me. Yeah. So Tim is doing great work.
He's actually an honest journalists on
the graph. He's new, he's on the ground,
like in the fricking dead center of
the graph. And from what I understand,
Tim pools, reactionary journalists, um,
idiots. I can hear laughter. Yeah, yeah.
Well we know what part we're using
as the promo now. Um, Tim Pool,
the half Korean white supremacist.
It's all so stupid. But, um,
Tim and also by the way, I think
for the record, if I'm not mistaken,
some of the connections that they
actually had to Tim don't even exist and a
bunch of other stuff. Okay.
Uh, Tim said and super chat.
They know they're lying about our views.
This is the death rattle
of an archaic media system.
We didn't really talk about
their bad intentions enough.
I think perhaps because I think
you, you always, and I try to,
I try not to judge people's intentions.
He's going right to their intentions here.
They know they're lying.
They know what they are,
they know they're lying and they think
that they're doing it in the service of
something beautiful.
Yeah.
Well then the problem is just the
reason I'm left off of this graph with,
uh,
this white supremacist Korean Tim Pool.
And again, I'm super sorry about that.
I know that if they would've asked,
I wouldn't know. Look, I'm trying to clue
for now your brother, everybody. I was,
I was too busy trying to organize
Nuremberg style rally. Um,
the reason that they leave us off
is because they can't handle the fact
that you have like a Bernie supporter
who's never voted Republican in
the supposedly reaction. I mean,
they're going after Tim pool like children
and they're trying to find something
that sticks all right? Doesn't
seem to work extreme, right?
Reactionary this, that,
and yet,
um,
let them empty their revolver because
they don't really have many bullets left.
Um, yes, they don't, they
know that they're lying,
but they think they're lying
in the service of good. And
I might lie in the service of good if
the good were extreme enough and the lie,
we're small enough so don't get upset
with somebody just because they're lying
in the service of put. Of course, they
know they're lying. And of course, uh,
they think they're doing it in the
service of good. But the point is,
we're going to have to live
with each other as a nation and
we're going to have to love each other.
And there are a lot of people with
this mimetic complex in their mind.
This is why I went and I talked to Kanye.
I thought what Kanye was going to do
was d trumpified Manga with people who
wanted their towns in Ohio and western
Pennsylvania to start working again.
People who, uh, you know,
we're drinking themselves silly feeling
that they were part of the American
dream and got sidelined.
We are going to have to find common cause
and it's just not that hard, you know,
it's just not that hard to have a friend
who's Hugh is different than yours is
not that hard to have a friend.
You and I have serious political
differences at this point.
It just doesn't cause me
to want to silence you.
And so my claim is,
is that even though they're lying and
even though they know they're lie,
you've got to experiment with love and
forgiveness to the best of your ability.
And I can't tell you
that I never lash out.
I think I lashed out a little bit at
Rebecca Lewis because she was lying.
She said it will never not be funny
that the entire intellectual dark web is
only located on Youtube.
Oh really?
So the 12 rules of life
isn't a book that exists.
And the waking up podcast isn't
something that has no video,
even if it's exists on youtube.
People listened to it off of Youtube
is it's not true that we don't have any
events. Of course, Rebecca
Lewis is like, she knows,
she's like Dana and society is lie.
These people all know that they're lying,
but they think that they're lying for
some beautiful reason to keep our country
together, to make sure that we're
not in the hands of a tyrant,
to make sure that every child has
a shot at a beautiful tomorrow.
And I'm sorry that they're this confused,
but have some compassion because
they don't have the compassion.
When we hear about empathy,
okay, the onus is on us.
They don't have this great empathy.
They like I Aye so care about Trans people
that I can't care about white people.
Okay,
that gives me a headache.
You're either empathic and you care
about people in general or it's selective
empathy and you really have
a lot of hate in your soul.
So I set it Goddamn example
that that's my basic take,
which is you've got to love
the people who are lying,
thinking that they're
advancing the world's cause,
and you have to love
them out of their cult.
And if we're not willing to take that on,
then I don't know what we're doing.
But I can't always make this,
this high bar that I'm setting for myself.
I will fail. I would lash out at somebody,
but have a forgiveness narrative.
There is in general, no redemptive
redemption narrative on the left.
That's why it's not even a religion.
People say it's a cult.
It's religion without a redemption
narrative. There's nothing.
If what you're really excited
about is sticking it to the man,
whoever the man is,
you're not fundamentally a good person.
You're a person who's working
through your own personal. And
so my claim is,
is that
love the people who are aligning against
you and figure out what an incredible
power, incredibly powerful weapon that
is. Because at the end of the day,
after you knock them
senseless to the pavement,
you better offer them a hand up
and say, look, it wasn't personal.
It's just you were, you were
threatening our system and you know,
I felt like I couldn't communicate to
you while you were still in the cult.
That's where I am.
I'm joining you on that adventure,
my friend the Ohio. There you go.
All right guys. That's it.
Remember October, fifth
wise guys in Salt Lake City.
We've got your links. You do have
a, uh, a custom name, by the way,
for your youtube channel. I'm going
to, it's gone. It was here before.
It's up.
It's up top guy.
It's Eric r Weinstein on Instagram.
And if you just search Eric
Weinstein on Youtube, it's on there.
Dave rubin.com/events for a bunch of more
standup stuff that I'm doing and we're
going to Europe with Peterson and a
whole bunch of other stuff. And, uh,
patrion.com/ruben report,
we're trying to get our Reuben
select members to 5,000 people.
We've got a great community
growing over there. Uh,
you want to get dinners on something?
Sounds like a plan. All
right. That's it. See Ya.